what kind of workouts did I do when I
was wrestling okay so this is going back
like 10 years and honestly I can't
exactly remember and that's mostly
because I had a terrible idea of what
constituted working out at the time uh I
didn't do any cardio outside of the
actual training that I would do in the
gym for actual wrestling training but
for actual bodybuilding then I would
just lift random weights but I think
that's pretty much the normal Place
anyone starts in eventually I learned
that it's better to Target specific
muscle groups during the week I would
have a three-day cycle day one would be
biceps and chest day two would be
triceps and back and day three would be
legs and shoulders I've since modified
that considerably particularly now since
I'm in a season where I'm kind of
running a lot more than I am lifting
weights basically what I'm saying is
train to the actual thing that you want
to aim for so like look to people that
have the physique that you want to try
to attain and then try to kind of like
maybe they've released some information
on how they train I hope that helped